Major breaking news as the United States
Supreme Court is getting ready in 24
hours to hear a huge case involving the
14th Amendment and birthright
citizenship. Specifically trying to
figure out whether or not children of
illegal aliens and children of people
like, I don't know, members of the
Chinese Communist Party that pop out
kids on American soil have given rise to
American citizens simply by virtue of
the fact they're born in America. or is
there something more to it? We know what
the 14th Amendment has to say about it
and we're going to break it down when we
come right back as to why President
Trump's position is the correct one.
Let's talk about it in a moment.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of Diner, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar
and I'm proud to say the top voice the
second amendment in America. Thank you
2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All right,
folks. So this is important. I want you
to understand this because there's going
to be a lot of misinformation out there
in the media. So, I want you to hear it
from me so you understand what's going
on. This is a super big deal, folks. As
you may recall, a month or so ago, we
had Peter Schwitzer on who explained in
great detail how the birth tourism
industry and how illegal aliens have
been exploiting the American welfare
system and the American system of
government in part by sneaking into
America either illegally or sneaking
into America by lying on visa forms to
have children who by virtue of the
long-standing interpretation by
left-wing judges is we'll get to that in
a moment. By virtue of their leftwing
interpretation of the 14th amendment
that's read out a major part of that
constitutional amendment, these
individuals who give birth to children
who have no connection to America other
than they happen to be here on the day
they're born. These children have become
immediate American citizens and serve as
anchor babies for the rest of their
families. even if those family members
are literally members of the Chinese
Communist Party. That's right. We won't
break down those details. We've covered
that in other videos. But I want to talk
about this case of Barbara versus Trump
being argued tomorrow about what is
going on here, how to understand this,
and why Donald Trump's position is
right. And why for so many decades
has this misinterpretation of the 14th
Amendment been the law of the land.
To begin with, let's start with where
where the issue arises from. The United
States Constitution has what's known as
the 14th Amendment. The 14th Amendment
was adopted in the year of our Lord,
1868. Why? Well, the 14th Amendment was
adopted immediately after the United
States Civil War. And what did we fight
the war over? Well, basically slavery,
right? And a big part of why the war was
fought, the Civil War was fought, was
because of a Supreme Court decision
called Dread Scott. All these dots are
going to be connected for you in a
moment. The DreadScott decision said
that African-Americans were not citizens
of the United States.
Years later, we fought the Civil War.
The Union won. The Confederacy lost. In
1868, the 14th Amendment was adopted.
The first sentence of the 14th amendment
reads as follows. And what it's designed
for is to describe who is an American
citizen. Specifically intending to make
sure that the African-American slaves
who had just been freed thanks to the
Civil War would be viewed as American
citizens moving forward. Here's the text
of the 14th Amendment, and they will
break it down in detail and add some
history to it. The 14th amendment
adopted in 1868 provides quote all
persons born or naturalized in the
United States
and
and subject to the jurisdiction thereof
are citizens of the United States and of
the state wherein they reside.
Take again look at the folks look at the
text folks. All persons born in the
United States and that's conjunctive
subject to the jurisdiction thereof are
citizens of the United States and the
state wherein they reside. Did you see
that text folks? To be a US citizen, it
is not enough to simply be born in the
United States. You have to be born in
the United States and you have to be
what's known as subject to the
jurisdiction thereof.
Now, what does subject to the
jurisdiction thereof mean? Well, we know
what it means. What it means is you're
not allowed to be loyal or to have
allegiance to a foreign power.
How do we know this? Remember I
mentioned to you the DreadScott decision
that said African-Americans
were not citizens and then we fought a
civil war thereafter and the 14th
amendment was adopted in 1868.
What happened in 1866? This is extremely
important to understand the history
here. In 1866,
Congress enacted a statute called the
Civil Rights Act of 1866.
The purpose of that statute was to
ensure that the freed African-American
slaves would be treated as citizens
moving forward. Here's the key language
from the Civil Rights Act of 1866. And
then you're going to see why the 14th
Amendment came about. Here it is. The
Civil Rights Act of 1866, a statute, not
a constitutional amendment. Check it
out. The Civil Rights Act of 1866
defined a citizen as one born in the
United States who is quote quote not
subject to a foreign power. That's
right. not subject to any foreign power.
Close quote. Civil Rights Act 1866. You
see that language in the Civil Rights
Act of 1866 adopted two years before the
14th Amendment. You born in the United
States and you're not subject to a
foreign power made you a citizen. So how
does that connect up to the 14th
Amendment which is being debated right
now? Because remember, the liberals and
the progressives in this case involving
President Trump want the children of
illegal aliens to be full-blown American
citizens so they can have unlimited
welfare and vote in our elections. They
want the children of the Chinese
Communist Party members and all sorts of
other people that travel to the United
States as tourists. They want those
children to be American citizens again
to replace you and to vote you out and
disenfranchise you and get rid of all
your constitutional rights including
your second amendment rights. Right?
That's what this is all about. So the
Civil Rights Act of 1866 was enacted by
Congress. But here's the rub. After this
occurred, members of Congress looked at
each other and said, "You know what? We
want this statute, the Civil Rights Act
of 1866, to override the Supreme Court
decision of Dread Scott. that said
blacks were not citizens. But we're not
sure constitutionally
can a congressional statute override a
Supreme Court decision. We're not sure
it can. Moreover,
a future Congress could come in and
enact a new statute that would get rid
of the Civil Rights Act of 1866 as a
statute. You see the problem? So what
Congress said is they looked at each
other and said, you know, we need to
make more permanent the notion that the
freed African-American slaves are
citizens and we want to make sure it
cannot be overridden down the road by
simply another statute, another law
enacted by Congress. So they said, why
don't we amend the Constitution? And
that is why they wrote the 14th
amendment. And the reason why the 14th
amendment reads that you're a US
citizen, all persons born in the United
States and subject to the jurisdiction
thereof are citizens is that the phrase
subject to the jurisdiction thereof is
synonymous with the language in the
Civil Rights Act of 1866, two years
earlier, that said a person is born in
the United States and quote not subject
to any foreign power.
That's the key. Because if you're an
illegal alien and you're the child of an
illegal alien, the parents are subject
to a foreign power because they're not
Americans and therefore they're not
subject to the jurisdiction of the
United States. Now, that doesn't mean,
by the way, subject to the jurisdiction
of the 14th Amendment doesn't mean they
can't comply with the law. They have to
comply, right? They still have to follow
like traffic signals. But the phrase
subject to the jurisdiction thereof in
the 14th amendment has a very specific
meaning. It's remember it's designed to
conify in the constitution the
significance of the statutory act in
1866 of Congress's enacted civil rights
act of 1866. So essentially you have to
interpret the subject of the
jurisdiction thereof in the 14th
amendment as meaning a person who's not
subject to a foreign power. And if again
the parents bring in the United States
and they're beholden to China because
they're Chinese citizens or they're from
Venezuela or wherever they are
allegiance runs to not the United
States. Now you may ask is there any
historical example of this in the real
world? And the answer is 100% yes. Why
do I say that? There was a group of
people born in America
in the late 19th century from 1868 at
the adoption of the 14th amendment all
the way into the early 20th century.
There was a whole group of people born
in the United States undeniably born in
the United States but they were not
American citizens because they were not
subject to the jurisdiction thereof. And
why is that? because they were beholden
to an old allegiance to a foreign power.
And who was this group? That would be
the Native Americans. The Indians. The
Indians who were not taxed, meaning they
had not become part of American society.
They owed an allegiance to a foreign
power in the form of their tribes. And
that's why it was not until 1924
with the enactment of a congressional
statute called the Snyder Act that the
Indians born in the United States were
not American citizens under the 14th
amendment even though they had to comply
with American law because they were not
subject to the jurisdiction thereof. And
the reason why they were not viewed as
having been subject to the jurisdiction
thereof is again they were beholden to
and had allegiance to and loyalty to a
foreign power i.e. They're Indian
tribes.
Now, all this history is being brought
to the Supreme Court this week. And you
may ask, Mark, how come for many, many
decades, we never talked about this?
We've never discussed this. No court has
ever resolved this. Isn't this prove
that the anti-American progressive
left-wing view of the world, which
anyone can sneak into America and plop
out an American citizen, the most
valuable asset ever, and just by virtue
of having the parents break into the
country and break all these laws, they
can have an American citizen that serves
an anchor baby to connect the family up
with all these welfare benefits?
Well, the reason why this issue has
never been squarely decided is because
of standing. Remember how I've explained
to you to understand that substantive
constitution you have to understand
process. Under article 3 of the US
Constitution, it says that federal
courts, including the Supreme Court, are
only allowed to hear what are known as
cases and controversies. Cases and
controversies. And we've talked about
this before. To have a case or
controversy in federal court, the
persons involved has to have what's
known as standing. And how do you have
standing to go to federal court to argue
your legal point to argue your case? The
answer is to have standing is you have
to be someone who is injured by someone
or something or a government act. So
here, the only people that have been
directly involved or directly
influenced, if you will, directly
impacted by this interpretation, this
wrong interpretation of the 14th
Amendment. In my view, the only people
that have been directly impacted are
whom? The children of the illegal
aliens, the children of the foreign
tourists that sneak into America to give
rise to an anchor baby. And guess what,
folks? None of those people, the parents
or the children have what? None of them
have been hurt. None of them have been
injured. They don't even have And why
would they sue to give themselves up
because they want this golden egg? They
want to be an American citizen. So the
people directly impacted by this benefit
from this wrongful interpretation of the
14th amendment and no one else who
disagrees with it had standing to go to
federal court and to sue. And this all
changed by virtue of the brilliant move
by President Trump and his team that
issued this executive order saying we're
no longer going to do this. And then the
illegal aliens and their advocates and
the NOS's had to sue Donald Trump over
this executive order. And that's how
this all got to court because now Trump
was not allowing them to be citizens
automatically anymore. Now they had to
sue because they were injured and now
we're in the Supreme Court. But anyone
that says, "Oh, well, we've never
interpreted the 14th Amendment this
way." Yeah. Because it was never
litigated because the people that got to
benefit from this scheme, if you will,
obviously we're not going to sue. And
the people that objected to this did not
have standing to sue because they were
not directly impacted and they're not
qualified for standing under article 3
of the Constitution. But I think this
sufficient for you to understand that
the Trump argument is very strong.
wrong. There's obviously arguments going
both ways because there's a lot of
people that have a vested interest in
replacing Americans with non-Americans.
Allah, the 1.2 million foreignb born
individuals in Virginia that obviously I
suspect are largely supporting the
Democrats and the quote unquote assault
weapon ban. You know what I think about
that? I made that clear. But
nevertheless, there you have it. So
again, if you have specific questions or
want more videos on this particular
topic, I'm happy to do it. Um, it's
super geeky and it does impact the
Second Amendment obviously because
again, if you replace Americans with
people with no heritage, tradition, or
connection to America or constitutional
rights, well, you know, I don't think
you're going to get it to an outcome
that you're going to want if you support
the right to bear arms. Okay, there you
have it, folks. Hope you enjoyed today's
episode. Make sure you follow me on X at
fourboxes. Don't forget to subscribe on
YouTube and Roman. I'll talk to you
again real soon here at the Four Boxes
Diner.
>> Orders up. Table 2A.